Okay, so today we're going to be talking about something that you know several times in the office this week.
And it is about your message that I'm getting some feedback from people's computer there.
So I'm going to unmute everybody so that I can hear you.
So you're going to have to post a little note so I can see that you want to be unmuted if you have a question because I was hearing myself in your speaker.
So we're going to talk about a big word today.
You're messing cephalon.
We're going to have a quiz on it at the end, so make sure you get this down.
But your messing cephalon is a part of the brain.
You have, if I put my hands on top of my head, that part of my brain that's underneath the skull there is called the cerebral cortex.
And that's what would be considered the newest part of the brain.
Some animals do not have a cerebral cortex that you have a deeper part of the brain or the paleocortex and the archaeocortex that control more instinctual things.
That's what we're going to talk about today that deeper part of the brain that controls more instinctual things.
So if we're a patient on this call and we tested you with the heart rate variability test where we put that little thing on your chest and it measured your sympathetic versus parasympathetic balance, that's what we're discussing here.
Remember we talked about that you have two sides to your nervous system, your voluntary nervous system and your involuntary nervous system.
That involuntary nervous system is called your autonomic nervous system.
So that autonomic or automatic nervous system controls all your organ function.
That's what we're talking about, that autonomic nervous system.
The autonomics are separated to distinct components, the sympathetic and the parasympathetics.
Why do I tell you all this because it is really important if you're dealing with any serious disease.
Your sympathetic are your fight or flight mechanism.
So in case you got a big scary situation that your sympathetic kick in, a policeman pulls you over, you feel the effects of your sympathetic kicked in.
Your heart rate went up, you feel a little flush, maybe you're sweating, your blood pressure is higher, your nervous, you can't really think straight, your eyes are dilated, your blood is shut to your extremities.
For the purpose of fleeing or fighting, so it's your fight flight mechanism.
So it's to deal with a crisis for a very short period of time.
You have a crisis in your life, your sympathetic kick in, if you're healthy, and you can fight that situation, and you can deal with that situation, and then it's done, and it goes back into normality.
So the sympathetic are not supposed to stay in a stuck on position.
Opposite side are the parasympathetics.
Their purpose is to stimulate your immune function, stimulate detoxification, stimulate gut function, stimulate sexual function, stimulate making white blood cells and making red blood cells.
All those things think of, we don't need any of those things to be taking place if a polar bear is chasing us.
So this is the mechanism that God gave us to deal with situations in our life.
If we're being chased by a polar bear, we don't need to worry about detoxifying, because we're going to get eaten by a polar bear.
So who cares if we die of mercury toxicity in our liver shuts down in 10 years, we have five minutes to get away from the polar bear.
We're getting chased by a polar bear. Our sexual function is going to shut down.
We don't need to procreate. We're not going to be long enough to see our children if we don't get away from the polar bear.
We're being chased by a polar bear. We don't need to make white blood cells and fight off an immune response.
Who cares if that virus kills us in seven days, we're going to get eaten in five minutes by a polar bear.
So when I have this heightened sympathetic stimulant, it's going to shut down my parasympathetics.
If for whatever reason in my life, we'll talk about those in a bit, I'm stuck in a hypersympathetic state.
I will have a lower impact of my parasympathetics, which are kind of essential for fighting any chronic disease.
So if I'm dealing with cancer, I need to have a healthy parasympathetic response.
So if I'm stuck in a sympathetic dominance, I'm going to have a more difficult time, not impossible, but a more difficult time fighting that cancer, because my parasympathetics, which stimulate an immune response, are going to be functioning relatively less healthy than my sympathetic.
So why this big word messants the fallen here, it's because the part of the brain that controls the sympathetic is in a part of the brain called the messence cephalon.
So the messence cephalon is in the deep part of the brain, it's part of the midbrain, and that's where the, that's where the origination of the sympathetic start.
And they go down your core, they come out your, mainly in your thoracic spine, and they do all sorts of different things.
Typically you'll see in a heightened sympathetic response, you're going to have a slightly increased blood pressure, you're going to have increased heart rate, you're going to have maybe more perspiration.
So you can see some, some diseases are really tied to a hypersympathetic state, first it has high blood pressure, it's piece of it from a neurological perspective is a sympathetic dominance, first it has hyperswetting, piece of it from a neurological perspective is sympathetic dominance.
Now there's other things with nitric oxide and vascular integrity and all these kind of things that we're not going to get into with those diseases though, but just talking about the balance we're talking about from a neurological perspective.
So these exercises, if I do have a hyper sympathetic response, we want to use these exercises, if I have this high firing messence cephalon activity.
So here's some simple general treatments for hyperbessence cephalon.
All right, so we could just read through this list, you can wear rose colored glasses, so color affects the midbrain.
And they found that rose color or amber color sunglasses, even where ward in the house can help calm the bessence cephalon.
So here's another sign that you have a hyper sympathetic dominance.
Boy, I, I'm very sensitive to sunlight, I need to wear sunglasses if I go outside.
Well, why? Because if I'm in a sympathetic state, one of the things the sympathetic nervous system does is it dilates my eyes so that I can run away from the polar bear.
So my eyes are a little slightly dilated more than they should be.
More sensitive to light, they don't contract the way they should.
And I'm going to be more sensitive to sunlight and they're going to want to wear sunglasses all the time.
So where it's a rose colored or amber colored glasses. Sometimes I found that slightly purplish glasses work better for some people. Everybody's a little bit different to see what you feel like calms you color affects the bessence cephalon.
Secondly, placing a cotton ball or one of those little earplugs or something in your right ear.
Because what you're doing is calming the noise that's coming from the right side into the right temporal lobe because stimulation of the left temporal lobe inhibits the bessence cephalon.
So putting a cotton ball or earplug in the right ear helps calm the bessence cephalon because you're inhibited it through the left temporal lobe.
I won't get into the details of that, but it works.
Breathing a foul smell, whatever you consider to be a foul or odor in your right nostril.
So you have to close your left nostril with your bigger and you breathe a sticky sock or something like that in your right nostril.
That will stimulate the frontal lobe to inhibit the bessence cephalon.
The parasympathetic will help calm the sympathetic.
The parasympathetic nervous system, the main nerve trunk of the parasympathetic is called radial nerve 10 or the vagus or vagal nerve and it innervates your throat at your larynx.
And it also innervates your other key point to hit for the parasympathetics is the rectal area.
That's one of the main reasons why coffee animals are so good for cancer patients who you read all coffee animals are so good because they help you detox. Well, yes, they do.
I think the main reason why coffee animals are so good for cancer patients because the caffeine stimulated the vagal nerve stimulates a parasympathetic reaction.
So humbied and gargolied can stimulate the parasympathetics, but to really get a good stimulation, you really got a gargle hard for a while.
What should I gargle? It doesn't make any difference.
Humbied and sigied and can help stimulate the parasympathetics, which will intern, calm down the sympathetic slow deep belly breathing can help stimulate a calming sensation to the sympathetic.
If you've made memory games like card games, you know, like you remember the concentration game where you have all the cards out, you've heard over a jack, the queen, oh, turn them back over, a queen or is that another queen.
Those could be helpful to stimulate a parasympathetic and actually what you're doing with the memory game, sorry, is you're stimulated front and low action and that is that inhibitory to the sympathetic.
So if you have a chi machine, that could be helpful, chi machine is one of those things you lay on your back and you put your feet in this thing that jiggles you back and for your legs in this thing, you put your ankles in this little apparatus that goes back and forth back and forth that it kind of jiggles your legs back and forth.
And it's could be good for a lymphatic congestion and your lower extremities, but it stimulates indirectly because it's stimulating the cerebellum.
Quite a good cerebellar exercise and then stimulated the frontal lobe any stimulation of the frontal lobe will be call me to the sympathetic because the the frontal lobe, your prefrontal cortex, fiery back onto the best and cephalod is inhibitory.
If you're going to stimulate the frontal lobe, you will inhibit the sympathetic.
Vibrational therapy, like a foot vibrator or those vibrating pads, everybody in their binder has a the back of the food section, the last page is a picture of a foot vibration plate that you can buy an Amazon for a couple hundred bucks, it's really a wonderful tool for brain therapy and it will help calm the sympathetic.
Dietary considerations to calm the sympathetic have to do with lowering your glutamate levels we're going to talk a little bit about that in a second.
Any inflammatory foods will stimulate can stimulate the best and cephalod like gluten dairy and also histamine can stimulate the best and cephalod emotional helps it's really important is that the big deal of the best and cephalod are very closely related.
You're a big deal is where where you house all your emotional memory so if you're abused as a child or or you just have memories of of emotional traumas in any way shape or form.
You don't compare those with somebody else there, what are they affecting you so any stimulus of memories can stimulate a sympathetic reaction and you've experienced everybody's experience that think of the you know your divorce or think of when you got audited by the IRS or think of when you were yell that by your mother or something like that you already feel your heart rate go up.
So dealing with those past emotions is extremely helpful so if you need counseling you need talk therapy you need somebody just to share that with you need to know to read a book about how to deal with that that's why we put that hard condition section in your binder.
bringing it to the Lord and really poured it out at his feet is is is a big help but sometimes you need help with that.
So we're going to switch to this little piece here i'm going to unmute people here so if you guys have questions you can talk.
And we're going to talk about that glutamate section here I know we touched on this last time on how bad it is for simulated mTOR pathways i think we talked about this last time and that stimulates cell reproduction which is what we don't want to do.
But glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter to the sympathetic to so glutamate right there is in a amino acid that's founded protein right especially if you have GAD or DAO G defects or glue G defects also you're going to produce a lot of glutamate and that's in itself stimulates mTOR but glutamate also stimulates we can have another.
If we're going to do this talk about just sympathetic here and we can have glutamate stimulating sympathetic stimulating best and cephalon up regulating best and cephalon so just more things to consider about how bad our food system is in putting glutamates and everything to make you addicted to them.
It did want to touch on this a little bit too and the glutamate section of the practitioners report any questions while this is opening up if anybody wants a copy of that form that this this form right here let me know and I could email it to you but you got to memorize for the quiz anyhow.
This is the glutamate piece that you look at when you're looking at how well does this person handle glutamate I didn't get to this last time we spoke about mTOR so I did this is what I wanted to talk about really is other factors that stimulate cancer growth with glutamates and it's these are the different genes that we're looking at.
So this happens to be a cancer patient that is just put it here as a sample and we look at her genes I gave her a way to female the SLC genes on this person has she's got a lot of SLC genes and much worse than the need of the population of this group but remember when we look at your genes and we look at this report.
The need on here is the 23,000 people that we have in this genetic this genetic software and they're not usually healthy people so they're typically people with some sort of ailment that's why they sought out our help and other doctors that use the same software.
So when you look at you know what I mean to the right of the meat if we didn't had a healthy cohort of people the need would be over here somewhere so we don't want to be to the right of the meat so this person already has definitely some of issues and be able to deal with glue to me and it's conversion to glutamate and it's their ability to get that out of their body.
Like this they're going to be probably to the left of the me and see that's better than the average there they don't have very many defects there.
The mTOR genes are tied to glutamate because of with more mTOR genes this is one of the cancer genes that we look at for cancer patients you're going to have an op regulation of all of this even if you didn't have any of this stuff going on.
So even if you didn't have any exposure to any of these things if you have a lot of mTOR genes this is going to be up regulated by itself that's why it is a what we consider a cancer gene.
So the thing that I remember that keeps this in check is the dearth to the glutam glutamate on pathway and the keep one genes.
Keras genes that's another pathway that feeds glutamated we need to expand this chart because keras feeds glutamate up on top up here is this fun.
So these are all the genes that we look at when we look at you know what could be driving a person's illness whether it be kids or live or anything else that we want to say wow maybe we need to go on a lower glutamate diet.
And lower glutamate diet because you convert it to glutamate and you don't just give your body every chance to call this down.
Does that make sense?
So those are the things that we want to look at to try to kind of try to manipulate the metabolism that's going on.
You know the problem is I wish it was just as easy as okay we're just going to cut this out of our diet and we're going to all get better and our body's going to stop making doing you know it's replication process and cancer is going to stop but all these things these bad things that take place with this are going to stop.
The truth is we're hit with so many pieces here and I was talking to a patient just this morning I think and I said oh I thought of something else and oh I got to add another box down here that fits that hits this it's like it gets exhausted it's like gosh we have just so destroyed our environment in our food supply.
I mean if dairy was natural and raw would it still have IGF one hormones people have asked me that yes it would because dairy is a food product for baby animals okay so dairy not because it's tainted or because it's poisoned or because there's antibiotics in it or hormones in it which there are.
But simply because it is a product for a baby to eat a baby cow or a baby human it has growth hormone in it because that's what helps that little baby calf grow up quickly so that's why you know we don't want any cancer patient on a lot of dairy.
I mean you don't really how many people do we really want to dairy anyhow whether you have kids or not because it has IGF wanted it that's that's intrinsic growth hormone right there this is intrinsic growth factor one that stimulates mTOR for the purpose of cell replication so this little baby calf can make a lot of muscle and grow and it cells replicated it gets bigger well we know what that if we have kids or not.
But really the protein drinks haven't been a essence that not only glutamine but methionine is a big baddie for stimulated mTOR production that's why we look at the MAT gene which we got to put right there so I understand that it's complicated but if we just take this in pieces then I think in the more times we hit this reputation wise then I think we'll understand that.
It gives you food for thought for at least like oh no I know why I'm doing my diet the way I'm doing it and gives me some stimulation to keep up with that process when we get frustrated because everybody else at the church social is eat junk food.
So all right does that help try to take this in pieces and keep them in a half an hour but here for questions if you have any questions no questions.
All right I will send out I will email everybody the quiz no ready for that all right make sure if you if you want to ask questions on Facebook you can ask whatever questions you want.
If I want if I feel it's more appropriate for your sake to answer over the phone or something we will call you to answer those if we kid or if we have to make an appointment we will do that too but keep up the good fight know your other right track and we are behind you all the way and we are praying for you every day literally every day I'm praying for my patients so I hope you're praying for us too because we are always under attack.
So we are always under attack too so be prayed for protection for us and we cherish that so thank you much I'm going to stop sharing this and we'll put this recorded up in just a little bit it'll be up on Facebook you guys have a great day.
You too.